Hello, welcome back. We are in the
third discussion on chapter 5 on
predictive coding.
We will have one more discussion on
Friday with Frasier on chapter 5 and
then that will conclude the part one
chapters and then we'll take next week
to review part one. Look at the
questions that have been asked on the
introduction and up through chapter 5.
Make sure they've all been addressed.
Talk about any other random questions.
Look a little bit more at the code. look
uh at any other uh topics that people
want to explore related to the first
part of the book and then we'll jump
into part two.
Let's today pick up with just looking at
the concept map and starting with is
there any specific area or a question
that somebody submitted before that they
want to start with or bring up right now
related to
Chapter 5.
Okay. So, we looked at the concept map
previously
and we'll probably return to it. And
I'll also just bring up this is the
chapter 5.
This is the
fundamentals open source code repo and I
just made a couple updates to the
chapter 5 code.
So all the methods are in here in SRC
modules.
They're all tested and documented using
core methods across the different
chapters. So you can see a little bit
more continuity there. And they're used
in this chapter specific fashion.
So if there's another type of figure or
another animation that you'd want to
explore, just make the request in a
group meeting or through any other way.
Okay,
we have some
questions already on chapter 5 and last
time we basically got to
I believe the uh maybe the end of
section 51. I don't exactly remember but
just is there in the chat or raising
their hand. Is there anything that
somebody wants to start with first
or just any random takes or impressions
that people got from reading chapter 5
or any overview or update on how does
predictive coding relate to active
inference?
Okay.
All right.
Um, well, there's a lot of ways to
continue about this.
Let's
briefly
look at what's going to happen in
section 53
and 54 as extensions
and then return to 52
to bring us back to the core kind of
Lego block of predictive coding because
it's good to know how these extensions
go and it's easier to take that jump to
extensions when you're familiar with
what the core method is.
So again to to recall in section 51 and
52 we basically get all of these core
mechanics
in terms of how do sum of squares
sum of precision weighted squared
prediction errors that's what we talked
a lot about last time relate to
meanbased updating of the variational
posterior And that's simple predictive
coding. Now let's peek ahead to the two
extensions, the multivariate case in 53
and the hierarchical case in 54. Then
return to 52 to the core. And then we'll
see if the questions have been addressed
and if we want to write any responses
there or if
um there's any other questions we want
to add and then just you can add to the
questions table if you have an
uncertainty including I I don't even
know what to ask which there's
definitely pages where that hits pretty
hard. All right. So
multivariate predictive coding.
So in the uh page 114
uh Sanjieve writes the model we have
investigated
so far is very limiting because most of
the useful scenarios that we wish to
model in the real world deal with
multivariate data. So, for example, not
just one thermometer, but you have a
whole bunch of thermometers, or not just
one EEG sensor, but you have 64 EEG
sensors on Morgan's skull cap or
whatever it is there. That's one type of
multivariate inference where you're
dealing with observation or sensor
channels and there's a bunch of them
that are like spatially distributed or
have other different attributes within a
modality like 64 thermometers or you
could have the multivaried situation
where the modalities are just totally
disperate like temperature and humidity
or it's EEG and color.
um second paragraph there, the
generative model now consists of a
vector of hidden states. And that's
basically the move that this section is
going to trace is just going from a
scalar single number to a vector and
then just continuing on analogically
with extending all of these calculations
into the vector setting, not just the
scalar setting. Uh, Thomas
>> Daniel, just because we're at that
point, um, XAR element of RC, that
should probably just be X, not XAR.
Good point. Xar would imply that it's
um,
the generative process consists of those
Xstar true values.
Good call. Thank you.
five. This is how to add era. By the
way, if you ever find any typo, please
just add add it add it yourself. And
then in just the very next sentence,
vector value function gore m and in
parenthes x that x should probably be a
bold x.
Yeah.
Should be regular. Yeah, good
opportunity to revisit Xstar
should be um Xstar is the real
generative process external state but
the generative model just uses X to
represent its estimate of the latent
state
that second one I'll I'll I'll let you
or someone else add.
Okay, thank you for that. Um, so the
move here is just to vectorize
latent states and or vectorize
observations. In general with state
space models,
this book is going to take the approach
where we start with like one
observation, one latent state, and then
we'll get to one action.
In general, you could have any number of
observations, any number of latent
states in the generative model, any
number of actuators. So you could have
like one observation getting unpacked
into many latent states
belief updating
or vice versa, you could have many
observation channels mapping to a
reduced number of latent states. So
those are just kind kind of the anatomy
or the morphology of these different
state space models.
Um,
example 55 on page 115
is going to be a twodimensional grid
example. So here those two dimensions
are
that's where xar is used correctly. Um
the external states of the environment
are indicated by the vector xstar.
is within that's the fancy sideways e
big r fancy r to the second power. So
real numbers and there's two dimensions
to that real number vector.
um like 0.5 comma 2.5 is the true
location of the food in this example
and the m subx11
is the agent's belief that's on the
generative model side on the agent side.
So that's an example where um both of
the latent dimensions are spatial
and then later down the page
um the observed data. So there's also
two dimensions to the observation data
can be interpreted as two different
types of sensory modality such as
arbitrary units of olfactory perception
and light intensity.
Um, so that's the
sort of cheese discovery example of
two-dimensional predictive coding.
Um,
in example 56,
there's the parameterized multivariate
predictive coding model. And that big
bold theta, the mixing matrix does a lot
of the work in
uh hinging variables that have different
shapes because the mixing matrix can can
be kind of like wide and shallow or it
could be very tall and and narrow and
that mediates it's kind of like an
experimental design matrix mapping from
whatever dimensionality of observations
you have to latent states.
And that example is on in equation 5.27
is two wide and four tall. So that's
like mapping
between a two and a fourdimensional
state space.
And um we can see from figure 514
we have
true two true x values. And then mu subx
is the mu is just a it's just Greek for
mean.
It's the
>> mean central tendency of those x
estimates. It'd be nice if they were
like numbered like sub one or sub
something. Um and
this is showing how as a function of
iterations which is to say like those
gradient descent gradient following
iterations
on on the variational free energy
landscape.
Those two estimates of latent states are
getting updated and then they hit this
stationerity pretty fast. And then
there's four input channels.
And so here's the overall variational
free energy dropping.
Um,
and I wonder if that should be 1 2 300
or if that's denominated differently.
It's not reflected as that way.
But we can look at equation 527
and see how it's two wide and four tall.
And then connect that to how there's two
latent states here and four
observations.
So that mixing matrix which is kind of
like the likelihood matrix overall is
mapping from any number of input
channels to any number of latent state
variables.
Okay. Any thoughts or questions on this
multivariate case?
Again, it's the intuition that is built
in the single dimensional, single
sensor, single latent state is going to
carry forth like pretty cleanly into the
multivariate case. And then again, we
haven't dealt yet with action, but we
will in the next chapter and uh next I
think one or two chapters. And action is
going to get tucked really nicely into
the way we've been talking about latent
state updates.
It's just a latent state that is under
the agency of the generative model.
Okay. Now, quick peep into section 54 on
the hierarchical predictive coding.
Okay. So, Sanjieve writes, "Hierarchical
models are useful way to represent more
complex features in the world that have
hierarchical structure. For example,
a face or a tree.
And this section will introduce the
concept of hierarchical model which will
be investigated in more detail in
chapter 8.
We can capture the hierarchical nature
of the world by extending the predictive
coding model discussed in the chapter by
introducing empirical prior the hallmark
of hierarchical basian modeling strategy
referred to as parametric empirical bay.
And what PEM is going to do is in
addressing that question like but how do
we pick our prior?
The answer of PEM is well take your
observations and then use the summary
statistics of your observations or a
batch of your observations or bootstrap
or resample or some other way to use the
data you have to set a prior regarding
itself essentially make it likely to
have been seen. So it's almost a quasi
frequentist approach because it sets
what could be a maximum likelihood prior
in a way that initially if you only had
that would be a bit like circular and
self-descriptive.
However, for going out of sample then
you have this empirically derived prior
rather than a a priori or like
aimatically set prior based on the data
that you have.
Okay, so we see the generative model in
equation 529
and it is going to be reflected in
figure 515.
So here we have a latent state
that is going to have an estimator for
the mean value of the latent state and
the variance
of the latent state and it is going to
have a variational family that's normal
Gaussian distribution
which is going to pull variables X
with mean invariance
m subx s^2 subx. So we have a gaussian
prior
on a latent state x.
Then there's this causal direction arrow
where x is going to emit observations y
which are shaded in gray.
observations
are going to be
parameterized by two features. They're
going to be parameterized by this g subm
mu of x
which is the generative function
generating function
intaking mu of x.
So that is basically the mapping between
latent state point estimates of central
tendency and the emitted observation
and a sigma squared suby like uh
observation noise as parameterized.
And then observations are going to be
parameterized by another normal
distribution that's going to give us y
observations
according to the g subm of mu of x
central tendency
with sigma squar suby
variance.
Mark.
>> Yeah, I'm gonna reveal my behindness
just a little bit here, but in asking
about that variable at the bottom that
the uh I think you have uh that that
could be seen as the likelihood.
Correct. the uh the term at the bottom
you just described or it's the
observation. But I'm I'm wondering if
that notation there is as described if
it uh reflects a likelihood in that it's
y the observation conditioned on I know
the notation doesn't suggest that but
could you say it's conditioned on the mu
of x in that way or am I am I just
reading that wrong?
>> Yeah. Yeah. you you said it correctly
which is we don't see a vertical line
the pipe so it's not that it's
conditioned on anything but yes does it
depend on like what does it how how do
you get a y well you get it from
>> the g subm of mu
>> mhm
>> that's going to give us the point
estimate of the central tendency of our
expected y given a mean of the latent
state and it depends on the on the um
variance sensor noise. So yeah, could
you say it's conditioned upon those two?
Yeah, basically it depends on them.
>> Technically it's parameterized by is
that
>> it's you could say it's parameterized by
those two variables or it's conditioned
upon them or it depends on them.
>> Sometimes conditioned is just using the
vertical line like X given Y. But yeah,
like in the sense that changes in those
variables influence their differences
that make differences, it is you could
say it's parameterized um dependent or
conditioned upon.
>> So could you characterize that as a
likelihood then
or
>> you would use the parameterized
distribution to calculate a likelihood?
And like a kind of intuition for why
that matters is like let's just say that
it was the distribution was
parameterized as like 10 plus or minus 5
then 9 is not so unlikely. But if it was
10 plus or minus 001 9 is super
unlikely. So the likelihood of an
observation given the parameterized
distribution is something you could talk
about but this is just stating it in a
generic way.
>> Yeah. Thank you so much. I on that point
I I uh recall reading somewhere in this
book um Sanjief is very particular about
keeping the semicolon distinct from the
pipe and I think he he does mention that
in general people
often uh use those two symbols
interchangeably
but Sanjief is is very particular about
keeping those apart. So the the pipe is
literally conditioned on but the
semicolon strictly means it's
parameterized by the following symbols
and he uses that as subscripts often. So
he's he's very he's very exact about
that.
>> Yep. Thank you. So this right here is
like this is the Drosophila. This is the
minimal setting where we're looking at
one latent state, one observation. We're
seeing it graphically though here with
the mean and the variance estimates for
each of them getting injected in latent
states emitting observations and then
the distributional notation on the side
there like equation 5.29
are these two equations. So those are
identical representations. the graph
contains that information except the the
n
and um
that's why 5.29 to mark's point the
likelihood is the probability
distribution of y given x.
So like it that's a true conditioned
likelihood whereas this is just being
stated as like the the equation. Okay,
so that was like a little bit of a
review of just latent states and
observations where they both have
separately parameterized normal
distributions. Then we're going to add a
third floor on the house in figure 516.
So now because we're talking about
potentially multiple higher order
layers, instead of calling the
observations Y, we're just going to
index them as mu subx
at layer zero. But you the the name or
the symbol of an equation doesn't
matter. It just needs to be
intrinsically coherent. And then we have
mu subx at layer 1, mu subx at layer 2.
So we know which language people speak
when they index at zero versus one. You
could call these layer 1 2 and three.
You could call this one y and the second
one x1 and x2. But here we're just using
the zeroth layer as the ground floor.
Then if you just were to ignore the top,
we would have exactly what we had
previously.
But rather than using like s squar for
x's variance component and sigma squar
for y's variance component, we're just
going to have a consistent nomclature
with sigma squared to the index
layer.
Um, and
we just add basically a prior on the
prior.
So it's just like adding the third floor
is going to relate down to the second
floor analogously to how the second
floor is going to relate down to the
ground floor.
And we see at each of these um layers we
have a normal distribution where mu subx
at layer zero observations
are being generated by the distribution
that's normal parameterized by
the generating function from
layers layer one's second story
point estimate and the sigma square of
zero sensor noise at the ground floor.
So that's how you make predictive models
that are hierarchical.
You just have another layer that
supervenes upon or sets a higher order
prior and you can keep going. So it's
not that there's a generic or even a
situation specific answer of where the
buck should stop. But the good news is
you know for a given generative model
where the buck does stop and you can use
principled methods like basian model
comparison, basian model reduction, baze
factor, all these different kinds of
features to select the order of model
that balances for example accuracy minus
complexity by rewarding models that fit
well and penalizing having extra
parameters. Magdalena.
>> Um, yeah. So, at this level of
abstraction, Daniel, could you uh walk
me through the uh generative model term?
So, at the level at the at the ground
level, you have the generative model
with the one which refers to the next
level. And then in the second level you
have generative model with two which
refers to the third level. And in the
third level there's no generative model
term. Why is that?
>> Yeah it's kind of that is where the buck
stops.
It has um that's why it has like a
slightly different notation like great
question though. Layer one and two are
almost exactly structural. They are
structurally identical. They're both
going to look up to another basian
variable, another latent state which
they are an emitted observation of.
So like here at the observation layer
that shaded gray we see that that is
going to get drawn from
the generating function and point
estimate of the first latent state and
its variance profile sigma squar of
zeroith index. Now exactly analogously
layer 1 second story is going to get
drawn
mu subx of index one from a normal
distribution parameterized by the
generating function of the point
estimate of
the third story second layer and the
noise component of first layer. Okay. So
if we were going to go in the infinite
recursion setting, then you just keep
going with that and you just keep on
bumping up those numbers by one. But
every building has a top story. So here
is that top layer where it is just being
parameterized in a slightly different
way.
That's that is where the buck stops for
that. For example, um let's just say
that we have uh the observation
of um
like we could think of this as a
three-digit number. We have like the
ones place, the tw's or the 10's place,
and then the hundredth's place. So just
like a three-digit number. And so we're
going to say, okay, we're going to be
sampling from that one's position of the
three-digit number, and it's going to
have its own sensor noise and stuff, but
also it's going to depend upon the state
of the 10. And then in that exact same
way, the 10's digit is going to have its
own sensor noise, and it's going to
depend upon the third position. And then
the third position you just say it's
being drawn from a uniform
or it's being drawn from just the number
seven or it's being drawn from 50% of a
seven and 50% of a five. So the top
level prior has like a little bit of a
different character because it is not
generated observation like from another
latent state.
What is a bit bothersome to me is
equation 5.32
does not um strictly align with what
we're seeing here.
>> Okay.
So
>> yeah, one one last thing.
>> Uhhuh. Does does the math the is there
anything in the math that presupposes
so a temporal sequence or is this a
hierarchy that is independent of any
temporal this has to happen first the
second this third
>> great question this is actually not
related to time
>> okay
>> this could just be like an inst it could
be like for example like the three-digit
number case doesn't have a temporality
or it could be like we're talking about
>> country, county, and city. So, it could
just be like instantaneous spatial,
>> but yes, you might fit it to time series
data. Okay, Kobas. Yeah, great point.
For example, um the 531
uses Y
for the first layer,
right? Is that what you're referring to?
Um yeah, I wasn't really studying the
relationship between 531 and 532, but I
just noticed 532
um the index on the left hand side is
different from the index on the first
term on the right hand side and that is
not the case in this this
>> graph. Yeah, good point. We should we'll
note not note this and someone could add
it to Arada or we'll revisit it but in
531 my my concern or question is that
the first layer is given with y as the
observation
and then the first layer is y
conditioned upon mu subx layer 1. So
that basically says that so either y is
equivalent to mu subx of zero and it's
just mislabeled or you would need
another edge from the zeroith layer to y
which seems a little bit less probable.
And then the second question is that
that you just raised there on 532 kobus
is we have um prediction error epsilon.
So we have epsilon layer little l which
is here indexed to zero
equals mu subx of l minus one
but that would be -1 if l were zero.
So
that is an inconsistency as well.
Um,
regardless in spirit
accurate, but this is like why the um
why without going too much into this,
why it's important to have like
multi-witness
rendering of manuscripts where the latte
plain text math is type checked against
the simulation and possibly even a
theorem proving environment because It's
and and there's a glossery with an
ontological lookup table because it's
really really easy to have variables
be referenced multiple ways or to to
lose track of indexing.
Where where we get with that though is
again staying with this notion where um
the lowest layer is mu subx of zero even
though it's kind of a little bit called
y. Um
we get descending predictions
and ascending prediction errors which
are not shown on this um on that base
graph. But if we remember back to how do
you set those priors with a parametric
empirical base that's basically like
what is happening with the prediction
going down but again that's just a
spatial association that's that's you
could have it left to right or whatever
and then coming up is empiricism. So
it's like idealism and empiricism
meeting in the middle pragmatism and
slightly updating. But you could you
could set it so that the mu subx a layer
1 never updates. It just relentlessly
issues the same prediction. Or you could
have a lightweight mu layer 1 that just
simply updates to the empirical layer
zero. That is the question of attention.
Okay, Mark, could you say each level
constitutes a mini generative model and
that those three are a chain of
generative models but referred to as the
hierarchical generative model? Um,
basically like if you just imagined that
you just had one variable by itself,
like we're just talking about um a
temperature in the room that just has a
mean and a variance. So kind of like the
simplest statistical variable or even
even simpler like a single parameter
model like a pson distribution like a
waiting time for a bus and just like
parameterized by 20 um
then you could have like a hierarchical
model that's composed of that and that's
kind of the power and the excitement of
graphical modeling
that this is like the Lego environment.
ments where you can compose generative
models of arbitrary structure and state
space composition and then you can do
local free energy based minimization
with message passing.
And with those local update rules,
that would compose nicely and accurately
into
equation 534, which is like the net free
energy. Like if you could if you were to
account for all of the belief updating
and variational free energies of each
node,
you could sum them without remainder.
There wouldn't be like another component
to incorporate.
So that is the idea and this is the
basic motif. We have observable
variables and unobserved variables.
And so those are the two kinds of
statistical variables. You know you got
inside and outside. Those are the two
kinds of variables.
And then you can compose the situation
where you have 500 latent states that
all cause down to one observation like
500 medical factors and is this person
going to survive or not or you could
have one latent state like do they have
a disease or not and then it could have
500 biometrics. So like you can compose
within that environment whatever state
space of model you want and then you you
wrote are predictions priors
basically yes the prior is like prior to
finding out what did you expect would
happen.
So that's that's why it's prior to the
observation
and then the posterior
updated belief after the observation
becomes the prior belief for the next
observation.
Um and
so we can
look at that in the graphics
in in the codebase.
So we can like see okay here's and here
in in in this version I I did
assume slashhypothesize
slashinfer that mu0 is y just to be
clear.
So here's like the observation is
clamped to two and then the beliefs are
updating
at these other layers to minimize the
per layer and the total free energy
given that clamped observation.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah. And
54.
Yep.
example 54
that this is just a slightly um this is
a example 54 uh or
it might be example 57 but I'm just
using like a little older PDF version a
little bit um yeah
similar okay and then section 55 gets to
the summary conclusion
so let's just look at those kind of that
the bathtub web style beginning and the
end of the paragraphs.
In this chapter, we introduced a very
simple implementation of predictive
coding as introduced
in Frist in 2005. The model introduced
the notion of prediction errors which
act as a feedback signal in the brain.
If observations are accordance with
expectations, don't change. Change to
some proportional extent and in the
direction of
Whatever the prediction error or
discrepancy is
absolutely
transformed into surprise
or bounded by a variational free energy.
Since the prediction errors are a
measure of uncertainty, when we minimize
VFE, we engage in the process of
reducing uncertainty in our model, which
is just the complement of maximizing
evidence in the model. If I would have
had what I if I if I would have known
and integrated what I know now, I would
have been less surprised by the
observation that just came in. If I
would have known then what I know now, I
would have had a better fitting model.
Ergo, I would have been less surprised
by the evidence coming in.
Um, we began with the E form of the VF
dot dot dot dot dot. Some
simplifications were made, some
rearrangements were made.
And that revealed a gradient descent
rule that could be used to estimate
values over iterations of variational
inference. Importantly, the iterations
of variational inference are not
necessarily the discrete time steps.
That's why we see like
dozens of iterations
because that but that could be happening
within one time step. And that's
something that like if you play with RX
infer you can explore is like how many
gradient to set iterations do I have the
budget for or am I going to um dictate
must be done
within a given time click.
Um third paragraph there the model has
clear connections to variational
inference but the formulation presented
here is different than the original
predictive coding paper which was the
row and Ballard 1999 which we recall
from last week. It doesn't go into the
variational side.
Um the predictive coding perspective
presented here is useful because it
demonstrates under assumptions about the
density free energy minimization is a
way of reducing uncertainty.
Then
um
predictive coding has roots in the study
of ganglen cells. So going back to the
50s some neuroscience citations you can
just look at the years there 57
80s 50s60s
and that led to the 1999 row and Ballard
work
and this notion of predictive error
minimization is related to a long line
of research in neuroscience reviewed by
that 2012 paper
and finally action has been recently
added to predictive coding models
producing active predictive coding that
is the same row in the 2023
which is kind of like a convergent
cousin of active inference.
And then that last section predictive
coding developed alongside a number of
basian methods that have been applied to
the brain which collectively loosely is
the basian brain hypothesis referring to
different aspects of like predictive
coding, predictive processing, the
pragmatic turn all these different
features. um probably approximately
correct or PAC computing
and
um
Pizulo at all 2024 described the way in
which many historical anticedants to
active inference unite to form a single
computational theory. Active inference
is not about the brain. It's more of a
systems science method that
is able to be used to describe the brain
and kind of continues to yes and all of
these like whatifs and alternative
systems
leading to the ability to specify active
inference generative models that
recapitulate or encompass or extend
variational approaches to for example
visual physiology. ology.
Okay. So, we could
return to some of the questions and
let's just see if there's any questions
to address
um now.
Okay.
Maximum entropy principle. So more
entropy is more choices or degrees of
freedom. Is this more options to learn?
And Andrew wrote, "Yes, the initial
distribution we use for making our
inference in principle should be high
entropy." So you can
um read Andrew's response there. And
I'll also bring in
this was live stream
with Thomas Parr
on uh active data selection
talking about basian clinical trials.
And in this set of streams in this
paper,
they go into the best detail of what are
the situations where epistemic value is
equivalent to maximum entropy. What are
different or better than maximum entropy
based sampling.
So if that is something that someone is
curious about, go into this active data
selection information seeking paper
which has
good discussion of the
maximum entropy
which is why I'll just leave it that.
Okay, page 118.
Is there any intuitive reason why we
define G subm equals Z for the top layer
so that the prediction error simply
becomes the mean of the prior? Now, this
is stated almost as a definition. I
wonder if there's a more principled
motivation for it. Yeah, the short
answer is like the buck has to stop
somewhere. You have to have some top
level of the building with a roof. You
have to have some top level variable
that's just going to be like it's just
this number or it's just drawn from this
distribution.
And then you could make another higher
order variable and make that more
complex than just stating it to be a
certain number.
But then that would just solve it for
one layer and just move the next layer
to be where the question was.
Page 118. prediction error becomes
equivalent to the current value of mu
subx.
So at the top layer the prediction error
just becomes equal to the current value
of mu subx. Should that be m subx
instead of mu subx?